Kylie Jenner officially becomes the
world's youngest billionaire I'm Kylie
Jenner and I am the founder of Kylie
cosmetics kylie is self-made Forbes
revealed Kylie was on track to hit the
milestone when they released their
America's richest self-made woman issue
last year the 21 year old Kylie
cosmetics creators company was estimated
to be worth nine hundred million dollars
but now Kylie has officially crossed the
billionaire mark passing up Mark
Zuckerberg who hit the milestone at 23
starting a company on my own and it
being so big from the beginning there's
not a lot of room for mistakes I'm the
face to my brand and I take
responsibility for everything that
happens Forbes reports that what shocked
Kylie up to billionaire status was
signing an exclusive deal with Ulta in
50 states instead of just selling her
products online and a pop-up shop
yep and the big debate before this
milestone moment did Kylie earn the
title self-made since she was born it's
a fortune I think she did of course back
in July the kardashian-jenner crew came
to Kylie's defense take a listen to what
they said to me self-made is when you
know everyone has a team I don't care
who you are how you you know but when
you don't get it from someone else
that's self-made so it's not like that
was handed to her she figured that all
out how did you feel about that when you
heard people had a problem with her
being a self-made billionaire well I
mean I look at it like this she made her
own money for over a decade she put it
in the bay she saved every nickel and
then when she decided she really you
know decided on what she wanted to do
she spent her money on a venture that
could have gone south or north and it
did really well so I think that takes
away from the fact that there was hard
work put into something I think that I
think that you that doesn't just happen
if you're
if you're not doing something about if
you're just sitting at home being lazy I
don't think that could happen
oops nice to see some good news coming
out of the car - at headquarters because
there has been cheating and cheating
rumors in that family and kylie is not
exempt to get you up to speed
last week a report surfaced that Travis
Scott canceled a concert in Buffalo New
York to be by his girlfriend's side
after she allegedly accused him of
infidelity
however Travis Scott denied this report
yes his rep told ET the show was
canceled because he was under the
weather quote Travis Scott vehemently
denies he cheated on Kylie it is not
true he did not cheat then over the
weekend a couple of things happened
during his show at Madison Square Garden
Travis gave Kylie a public shout-out
saying I love you why pee in a TMZ video
mm-hmm and then he deleted his entire
Instagram account which was a little
strange
of course by Tuesday it was back up
again who knows I gotta say you know
people can say what they want about
Travis publicly praising Kylie being
related to cheating but he does that all
the time when he has included her in his
music videos he loves her so much yeah I
just don't know if it's related I don't
think so either they always call each
other hubby and wifey I mean let's just
focus on the success that Kylie has had
being a billionaire let's focus on that
guy's but let us know your thoughts on
this whole thing I'm at Kourtney
underscore teza know and I'm at ash
Crossin until next time we've got you
covered
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]